sin duda el acción el trabajo y la
acción y el acción han sido el pilar del
discurso del presidente esta mañana
durante la ceremonia
acción con varios temas una acción para
evitar la escalada por cierto escalada
de tensiones y de la guerra a las
puertas de la unión europea pero a la
acción también para favorecer el empleo
el pleno empleo dijo el acción para
favorecer la unidad social para romper
con una forma de terna de determinismo
social y una acción obviamente para
favorecer esa transición económica
ecológica lo han dicho perfectamente
bien es decir una acción para contestar
a los desafíos de tiempos muy
particulares eso es la visión global en
la cual se inscribe un presidente para
un nuevo mandato
como bien dijo no se trata de
administrar o de seguir administrando se
trata de acompañar la transformación de
un país para que vuelva más
independiente en una europa fuerte bueno
y se aproximan las elecciones
legislativas de junio que son una clave
para la gobernabilidad del mandatario y
en las que tanto la izquierda que se ha
unificado como la derecha apuestan a
ganar espacios como de las perspectivas
electorales para el partido renacimiento
como se llama ahora el el movimiento de
manuel ma com
pues es cierto que el desafío puramente
político hoy en día es consiste en ganar
las elecciones legislativas que tienen
lugar en el transcurso del mes de junio
segunda y última vuelta el 19 de junio
en francia la metrópolis en el exterior
para los grandes desde el exterior el 18
el desafío es importante porque en
francia tener la mayoría permite al
presidente nombrar un jefe de gobierno
que surge de esa mayoría y le que le
permite llevar a cabo la política sobre
la cual ha sido elegido yo quisiera
recordar que el manuel marco ganó fue
reelegido con más de 58 por ciento es
decir
una buena mayoría o usted se refirió a
la extrema derecha cuya candidata obtuvo
41 es decir que hay 17 puntos de
diferencia pero bueno ahora se trata de
tener una mayoría y obviamente muy bien
lo recordó valentín a la izquierda como
por supuesto los los nacionalistas
también pues están trabajando para tener
una representación y por cierto se están
constituyendo
plataformas de partidos la plataforma de
manuel marco se llama juntos juntos es
una plataforma con tres pilares
renacimiento muy bien lo dijo el partido
de imán y el macro horizonte el partido
de uno de sus ex jefe de gobierno
eduardo y el partido de centro módem de
françois bayrou es decir que es una
plataforma de alianzas cuyas
perspectivas obviamente es ganar esa
legislativas para dar el manuel marcó
una mayoría que le permitiera gobernar
para los cinco próximos años pues en
youtube oa usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por que advertirlo con
nosotros en france 24